9 30 on uh June
27th I'd like to call to order the work
session on the special committee on uh
the Family Division
uh
as you see in the calendar and what we
talked about when we last met two weeks
ago this is a work session
um we're not taking testimony today
we are
meeting in order to assess
what areas committee members might
be working on in the next few months
because the committee
under
house rules will not be meeting again as
a committee until September
so that gives us time to go through a
lot of materials that have been
submitted to us and also materials that
we would like to read
so that we can come back in the fall
again ready to
um
move forward on on what will be a report
that we file and the expectation is that
that will be sometime
before November
and there are obviously two major
avenues that we can pursue one of them
um would be
um once we get past our general
comments would be a suggestion of
legislation that we think could help the
family uh courts better meet the needs
of the citizens of the state and another
would be
suggestions
to the um
to the separate branch of the um the
judicial branch which is of course
separated from the legislative branch
about areas that they might look into
where we think
there could be things that they could do
in their jurisdiction that would again
make the family courts best meet the
needs of the citizens of the state so
that's our general plan I want to repeat
yet again something that has been said
any number of times but when people
feel deeply about things they don't
necessarily listen because they're
waiting to say what they want to say and
I want to repeat once again under no
circumstances and never was it
considered nor will it be considered
that this committee will act as if it
were a trial or Appellate Court
to to take any action on specific cases
that have been filed and have been acted
on and under no circumstances
um will we be
um
uh changing
any decisions that have been made by the
core
those actions must be taken by the
judicial branch if the judicial branch
chooses to do so the legislative branch
is separate from the judicial branch and
we will do what we can to fulfill our
obligations
um in in terms of creating policy and so
um I know that no matter how many times
we've said this
people who are feeling deeply concerned
still want to
uh
I still are hoping that somehow
magic will fall from the sky and the
judicial branch will take on
um well the legislature will take on
judicial responsibilities and we will
not do that we respect the separation of
powers and so I want everybody to be
clear about that however we have heard a
lot of testimony up until now from a
range of witnesses from people who are
Advocates people who have professional
responsibilities and people who have
felt that the courts have not met their
their concerns and all of that we will
now have some time over the summer to
review and to think about and to learn
from people's experiences but I I do
want to repeat
for what's probably the 30th time we are
not an appellate court we are not a
trial court we will in no way
be involved through this body in any
review of judicial actions that would
you know would appear to be
um
appealing or retrying cases that have
been heard before the judicial branch
and um does anyone on the committee have
anything they'd like to add to that
representative long
thank you madam chair so uh yeah I was
looking for a report but
this special committee is not reporting
out we're just recommending uh
legislation
so
it's not even a report that we're giving
out it's
our charge is just to recommend
legislation if we see fit I I think
that's absolutely true but as we all
know it might come to pass in the
fullness of time that as we see how
things have unfold unfolded it might be
appropriate for us to set a context
for what we're going to do
um
but I I appreciate your comment and it
does you know remind us that there are
limits to all that we do or that we can
do does anybody else have any comments
no
okay
um
since we last met two weeks ago we were
not permitted by the speaker to meet
last week because during Committee of
conference week there are so many things
going on the staff is is so involved and
even the committee rooms
are involved so that regular committees
can or special committees cannot meet
during that week and so we did meet
um
uh
uh we did not have a committee meeting
but those of us who had scheduling
flexibilities were some of us were able
to visit
family courts in three different
locations Nashua Concord and Laconia and
I believe everyone found the visits to
be instructive
um and it is always helpful to see
for ourselves what
the physical facilities look like what
the tone is
um
and and we all observed
any number of cases some of us as many
as five or six some of us two or three
but I think everybody found that to be
quite instructive
um
so here we are now
um and the task before us today is to
try to determine
where and we would like
to spend our energies over the next
couple of months individually
um or perhaps a couple of people from in
the committee working together but never
more than that
um
because all our work uh is done under
right to know so that
um you know the full committee would
never meet
um or even the subcommittee would never
meet in any venue that wasn't posted in
the calendar
but there is a lot of research that we
want to do in a lot of areas we want to
pursue and so I would like to know from
my colleagues what they're thinking
about
representative Greg
so what you're asking what we would like
to focus on to work on each individual
so I the gal is a big thing for me the
guardian ad litem I think that we have
some work we can definitely do within
that space and I'd like to look further
into that
is there something that you want do you
want to develop that idea now or do you
want to wait and
wait well I think
um
I think while you know there's a couple
things that it's you know that we don't
fund it anymore so that people you know
who have need to do it cannot get it you
know it's only for people who can afford
it which sets up kind of an unfair
system in that but also just looking at
the gala as far as you know what their
you know they're not supposed to be
giving recommendations right now and
they are lawyers I would like to see you
know I've seen in other states where
they expand that to have people with you
know psychological you know degrees and
backgrounds that are able to really look
at situations especially when we get
into like domestic violence situations
and be able to be a little bit more
knowledgeable as far as to all the
psychology that goes into those
situations so I'd like to see if there's
something we can you know tweak within
that to help the situation because I
think you know a lot of times it seems
to be what we're looking at in these
situations
thank you representative GAO certainly
has been an issue that has come up in a
number of different Avenues does anybody
else have any feelings about that yes
foreign
thank you uh chairwoman so
I agree that there you know the gal
issue does need to be looked into I
think
we should expand it perhaps or consider
expanding it also into
making sure that the qualifications of
the gals are really there and that there
is some sort of training to not have
bias like everybody inherently is going
to have some sort of bias either way and
we want to make sure that if gals are
going to be looking into cases like this
that you know we've heard lots of
testimony about
you know people feeling that the gals
were unfair and I think in order to
you know mitigate that there needs to be
some sort of guidelines and training if
we're going to involve gals more to make
sure that they're not going to be just
coming in and we're using them more and
we're having more and more people feel
that there was a bias against them
um and I'm not sure exactly how we do
that I do
have a little bit of a concern with
um
as well with the gals that in the
majority of the cases that I saw when a
gal was hired they were ordering a
mental health evaluation and to me that
shouldn't be the standard of care so to
speak that we're automatically ordering
a mental health evaluation yes parents
are coming in they're emotional about
their children of course they are it's
their kids their babies but that doesn't
mean that they're mentally ill and it I
feel like there's this presumption that
we need to rule out if they are or are
not mentally ill and I just those are
expensive evaluations that that people
are subject to and when you think about
it you know when I was looking through
some of the data because it's not
medically necessary it's not covered by
health insurance people are paying for
these out of their own pockets and it's
like at an expensive four thousand
dollars when you consider that there's a
decent amount of people that only make
forty thousand dollars a year that's ten
percent of their yearly salary to pay
for this mental health evaluation that's
very much so probably unnecessary you
know unless there's an actual evidence
presented I don't think that that should
be a standard that's just ordered we're
going to order this mental health
evaluation to rule it out unless there's
actual evidence that somebody has
some sort of issue that needs to be
further explored I just I do have great
concern about that area of it as well
not sure your thoughts on that
representative if I could just for a
moment representative McBeth we're
starting by talking about areas that we
think we would like to focus some energy
over the next focused uh energy over the
next few months trying to go through the
the Myriad documents that we have and
figure out ways that we might help
um
make sure that we have the best possible
system and that's what we're talking
about now representative
hi thank you I guess people didn't hear
me earlier with what I was saying
because I was talking sideways sorry
learning curve so what I was saying is
is I would like to say this and then
I'll respond to um
to my colleague but that I on the gal
system I'd like to look into that
because I know there's other states
where they employ rather than just
lawyers or people with legal backgrounds
people that have psychological
backgrounds to do this kind of work so
that the complications of domestic
violence and stuff are a little
um
you know it's not so uh obscure or
whatever they can actually they have a
background they have knowledge to what
this looks like because there's many
times when you know it it could be the
actual abuser claiming to be a victim
and stuff there's a lot of complications
when it comes to domestic violence so um
as to what
you know ordering mental health
evaluations I think that's part of kind
of goes into this that's one of those
things I don't think it's necessarily
that they're always in the cases that I
looked at uh doing it because they think
somebody's mentally ill it's that
they're trying to understand a
background I know a lot of when there
are domestic violence and there's a
parental rights evaluation or whatever
they'll look at they'll do like an
evaluation of both parents because
that's kind of how you work to tell not
if somebody's mentally ill but if what
the underlying issues are so that they
can best evaluate like what's going on
with the kids and stuff but once again I
think
that's one of those things with this gal
that's a little more specific than what
they're really necessarily designed to
do at this time so I do agree that
that's something that we kind of need to
look into as to how they're doing that
thank you representative Macbeth I don't
want to put you on the spot and you can
say no but I um
um I seem to recall that you have given
us the clearest
um
uh definition of the two different
tracts of gal
um that exist in the state
um is that something that
you're prepared to share with us now or
would you rather not
thank you and I would like to just
mention I think that I think the gal
process what I think what thank you what
representative Smith is talking about is
the different tracks between the
guardian of the items that are certified
through the licensure office office of
licensure and the gals that are Casa
volunteers so I don't know much about
the casa volunteers prior to about 10
years ago the majority of the Guardian
ad items in New Hampshire were those
ones certified by the state going
through that training and um and I
understand there is a connection between
the two and some separations as far as
how they're disciplined or but anyway
um but when the state stopped funding
Guardian ad items for family cases where
the clients were at some percentage of
poverty level or whatever that's when
the state then relied much more heavily
and there was the this more you know and
more leaning on the volunteer causes the
um and uh what are they like children
their children Advocates I do see some
differences in the groups and I I want
to become more educated about that but I
know as a guardian ad litem and I'm one
certified by the state and in the family
court and the superior court and Probate
Court my job my role is a fact finder
for the court
um I know that I hear when Casa
volunteers talk about their role they're
a voice for the child so there's a
little bit difference in that and I'm
not sure how much they co-mingle and if
our language is just different but I
know that um of course the the miners
um
welfare and best interest is both of
ours number one concern but depending on
the age of the child and also some of
the psychological why they may if they
may be influenced to say one thing or
another their opinion while if it's
obtained it's generally shared with the
court it's not the end all you know I
just want to say
um and I'm interested in some of the
documentation that uh representative
data that you've looked at could talk
about the mental health evaluations
um my experiences when you get an
appointment to be a guardian of the
Litem the judge has to court has signs
off and checks very specifically what if
you're a guardian ad litem and I believe
it's for Casa as well what you can look
at so my appointment I can only address
or I'm to only address those issues that
the court has checked off and in my you
know again we're talking I don't know
what the percentage is but only a small
percentage of marital cases have
guardianed items or I I don't know if
you know what it is I don't but I know
it's not the majority and they're also
so when I get them they're very usually
very difficult cases that have gone on
for a long time and I wouldn't I would
say just maybe in half of those does the
court suggest that I make a
recommendation or look into the
possibility of whether a psychological
evaluation was important they are very
expensive and sometimes people can't get
them because they're not indicated and I
think that's something we need to talk
about Judges if they are
um you know but if if they are checked
off on that form and I'd like to know
how frequently they are because my
experience my experience which is just
me is that they're not rarely checked
off and even if I have some background
the the judge always you know does not
is free not to take my recommendations
or my my you know I don't again I'm
supposed to be a fact finder so I list
facts why it might be appropriate for
the court to recommend this I generally
don't say this parent needs one if
that's what the court and then the court
weighs that
um but uh I think the other issue is
someone you know mental illness is a
pretty big umbrella and I think that
having that evaluation is critical for
the background it doesn't mean that
you're you can't be a parent it just
means are you being treated and um
because I think the majority I don't
know I would
certainly in my family more than half
people have mental illnesses so at one
time or another so I don't think that's
a I think what we're looking for is not
necessarily A Mental Illness but maybe
some I mean that as well but I think
it's a broader just terms the
psychological makeup that might be
causing some reactivity or conflict or
something like that but I just I guess I
just want to just put that in my my
experience that someone having a label
of a mental illness which can be
depression add I mean I'm taking all
that stuff
um that doesn't preclude you from being
um uh you know having parenting rights
in my experience if it's an untreated
um you know if you have a some type of
schizophrenia something that's untreated
or even add maybe that's untreated and
you never show up for parenting or
whatever I'm not saying but I think
that's what the court is looking like is
this person following through on the
treatment plan you know are they going
to appointments that type of stuff so I
just don't want to give mental illness a
kind of a bad name and um but um I I
again and I'm sorry to come in late and
then but I I would really like more
education and I think
um parents need more education in the
courts on these two different tracks of
of
gals and I I think they're really we
should have the same type platform and
Education and Training and also
expectations of what we're going to
provide to the court and I'm I'm not
clear that that's always true and I
think that would be critical to give
families a more transparent and
consistent experience
um because when again I I see there is a
dichotomy in my limited space and not
better or worse different and I think
that
um then makes the experience different
and again I think the big thing about
Family Court is managing expectations
and if people have an expectation of
their attorney or the judge or the gal
and it's you know it's not what's
happening I I what I've heard from the
testimony that's generally what causes a
lot of problems people are expecting one
thing and yet another or so I I do agree
I think this is something to look at I
I also the issue of I don't know if
you've mentioned it but the issue of one
parent paying and the other one not
um that that's an issue I I mean I I'm
not sure why but State decided to stop
funding these in the family court now it
still finds funds gals Guardian Adel
items in the probate court and in the
Superior Court to a certain extent again
to um financially
um needy people so
thank you
um yes representative Lancer
so um not only do
um let's say
um after visiting the court
um in uh Concord
um the parenting visitation centers I
feel like somehow they need to
um I guess we've closed a lot of the
centers throughout the state and I think
somehow those need to be possibly looked
at and figured out if there's a better
way so that parents have the right to
see their children when they're able to
um and um and in you know in supervision
um representative line so do you know
who um
uh who paid for the parenting centers
um I no I do not was that in part of the
because I'm not familiar with that and
part of the
um the judicial branch budget
or or is it part of DH
so my understanding is they were
independently owned I don't know if they
were licensed by the state but the the
visiting parent had to pay and that was
also a a high
you know it was expensive for people I
don't know what the state ever did run
any I know that they've closed down I
know there was one in Portsmouth that
was operated by a guardian ad litem and
an attorney and it closed down to I mean
two years ago or three I mean they're
just I think they were very expensive to
have you know you had to have two
entrances at entrance for
um the child to come in with the one
parent in a waiting room you had to have
the entrance for the um other the parent
that was being supervised you had to
have you know a play area for them you
know too and you had to have a glass
window that was you know so somebody
could be supervising and also audio so
they could hear what was going on and
sometimes you had to have an individual
in the room so it's an expensive
Endeavor and I don't believe they were
state funded there may have been some
money but from my understanding they
were private contracts
and we I think we all know historically
that there was an incident
so I don't didn't know a lot about it
but what I'm um heard from a lot of the
parents is just that it seems like
they're having difficulty
um
finding it a place that they can
actually change off even with
transporting a child into the other
parent
and then also having needing a
supervision and sometimes they'd have to
go to a police station with the child
and I don't know if that's the most
appropriate place for the children to
each time have to have that happen so I
was just thinking for the children
as well so
you know what troubles me about this is
is this something that
the the concern is legitimate is the
solution something that belongs to
the judicial branch
um
and and I don't know the answer I mean I
you know I don't know the answer
representative
so I'm not sure about that but I I do I
do have a lot of concern about expanding
the visitation centers because I do
think in general that if a family member
can supervise you know if there's a
parent that you know there is actual
evidence that they may be of you know
harm potential harm to the child I think
that that the least restrictive
environment for that parent to visit
with the child is ultimately what's in
the best interest of everybody and if
that means having you know a grandparent
of the child supervising the visitation
or whatnot somebody that's familiar to
the child in a familiar environment I
think that that's much
better for the child to be you know with
known people than for
and I and regarding like the exchange
off I hear you're concern about the
police station I've always you know
taught my kids you know never to be
afraid of the police or the firemen or
whatnot because I want them to know that
they can go somewhere for help yeah no
but I in the sense of I don't associate
like going to the police station with
trouble I just associate it with you
know they help people so in that regard
I don't necessarily think that it has a
bad connotation of exchanging there I
know a lot of parents who do Exchange in
the beginning of their divorce at the
police station just because they're high
conflict and they like that there's
security cameras outside of the police
station and if there were to be some
disagreement that they know that there's
a police officer inside and I've asked
at least in my town if the police
station minds and they don't mind at all
if somebody feels you know more
comfortable exchanging in their parking
lot they're perfectly fine with it they
don't have any issues with it the
parents aren't actually going inside
they're usually just exchanging the
kiddos in the parking lot
um so I would kind of be more in favor
of
not necessarily going I think I think
the you know the visitation centers
take away from the parenting that the
parents actually can do because they're
in you know this
kind of sterile room so to speak with
their kiddos and it's not is that really
great parenting time with their child
represented along
thank you madam chair uh so
representative Macbeth and I witnessed
the case where in the final decree the
uh one of the parents was to have a laid
act evaluation
and the the party said I didn't even
look at my final degree now the other
party was concerned about visitations
because of the drinking and that what
why they separated and and the party was
still concerned about the drinking and
and
you know three weeks three months have
gone by and you know the children have
told stories of what's happening when
this party is drinking
um so that there there was no really no
fix I mean a supervised visitation could
have been a fix because now
you know the judge recommended that you
get a laid act evaluation ASAP so in the
meantime until the next hearing
the children got to go to the other
party
with the other parent being concerned of
the drinking
um so it's so I think and then and I
know in Manchester
um
the Manchester Police Department is
called often if they're gonna If the
parents are gonna meet in the parking
lot
uh they call uh they call the police
department and they ask for somebody to
be there and they'll if they have
somebody available they'll have them
there and that has gone you know instead
of having to meet at the police station
so they have also have done that and I'm
wondering on um
on mental health evaluations is is that
always a
a clinical clinician that's doing those
evaluations always it's not okay so
there's no other way so it's always a
because uh because the laidac
um
I don't believe they're clinicians I
think latex they're
I don't know I don't know what a layback
is I'm licensed alcohol and drug okay
if somebody hasn't actually been found
to have like had an alcohol problem in
terms of they don't have like a previous
DUI or something like that
I do have a little bit of a concern
about how much presumption we're taking
that they can't see their kids you know
like and I and I do know of cases where
they're ha you know I have been
alcoholic parents where they had
supervised visitation by grandparents
the grandparents slept over at their
house for the night and supervised
transporting the child back and forth
um so I think even in those cases it's
still the supervision still could be
done you know in a less restrictive
environment than in a supervised
Center but I mean I guess to your point
if if a police officers are willing to
meet in a parking lot they're standing
there I mean a police officer is trained
to know if somebody is intoxicated or
whatnot I don't know
obviously there's there's a lot of
questions about that oh representative
Paul
thank you madam chairman
um so I just wanted to kind of go back
Circle back to the casa I was trained as
a casa it was many years ago and now
coming forward to the conversation we're
having now the child
um that was removed from the parent
um was removed because drugs were found
next to the crib or another time because
drugs were found next to his car seat
however because the ten-year-old sister
was not in the house when the drugs were
found and was not in the car when the
drugs were found she was not removed
from the parent
so it's interesting that in this case
when you have a parent who's drinking
but there's been no allegations of them
driving with the child or putting the
Child In Harm's Way
um we're going to use that as a reason
to lessen their visitation or require a
stronger visitation when yet when we're
looking at the other court that's not a
reason to remove that child from the
home or from the parent and then just to
go back Casa is at least one and it
could have changed over the years but
when I was trained I was to be a voice
for the child and I went to all the
meetings and I I went to the house and I
looked at the house for make sure it was
safe
um
but I didn't give any opinions although
I was asked what you know is a child
safe and whatever but I just wanted to
clarify that thank you
representative Macbeth thank you so one
thing I'm really struck by is the
overlap of we've got the police and
we've got dcyf because as far as
removing a child and just removing one
that would have been not the quartz that
would have been dcyf I believe we've got
you know the office of licensure and
gals we've got the judicial uh and
they're I think some communication I
think that looking at the 10 000 foot
View
some type of coordination and best
practices
and really talking one of the things I'm
struck by with some of the antidotes
that we've got here and again and I I
really resist antidotes but the thing
about the police station I've had some
parents I mean they say it's just like
going to school the the police off they
have a drop-off Lane you can either do
it for kids or Amazon you know not
Amazon but Facebook or I mean I don't
mean to put I don't mean to make light
of it but it is something that is
monitored it's a lane that monitored the
police you don't necessarily call in you
know it's just something you know that
that safety is there for you someone's
going to be watching you know the
windows there
versus places where you pick the police
station but you don't know whether they
have cameras where you're parked or
whatever so I think that that's what I'm
talking about maybe coordinating this
because I know as far as um and the
courts when I do a parenting plan I ask
the parents what time is good and if
they don't know then I just pick a time
you know what would be good for me on
Friday night to change or Sunday night
to change I just thought wouldn't it be
great and then the court looks at the
parenting plan and you know makes a
decision but wouldn't it be great if we
talked to police stations if that's what
we're going to be suggesting people do a
transfer at and say you know what time
of day is good for you I mean it still
has to be good for the family I'm not
saying that but the other thing I wanted
to again this is my experience I'm
representative qatab and I'd be
interested because it sounds like you
had some data as far as what guardian
and items we're recommending and stuff
it is only in the most severe cases that
these um supervised parenting centers
are being used and I'm talking about
when uh you know I mean you know you've
got several different parents involved
parents maybe a biological parent that's
now lost their a bit but
addiction children people that okay I'm
just gonna say people parents that have
tried to commit suicide with their
children in bed with them people that
are have been convicted of assaulting
their child and breaking a bone
um and then people that are in active
addiction trying to get help but they
can't and so having the drugs that were
mentioned here and we have so much of
that and grandparents a lot of times
family have already done that hands off
until you're in treatment so you don't
have family members that can and you
know the the bottom line is what a lot
of counselors and people know is that if
a child loses all contact with a
significant adult a parent or
grandparent that has been in their life
they can suffer significant you know
issues later on so it's not just this
parents right it's really the child's
right too to not have that withdrawal or
that um you know alienation that does
happen that so I mean and I do support
the parenting rights I just want to say
I also
um as a guardian light and look at
everybody's rights I mean and and it is
the child's right to to have some still
maintain that contact in a safe place
and it can only be every two or three
you know whatever they can work out so
um but I would be interested and I don't
know if there are data because it sounds
like you might have had some about the
mental health recommendations and these
but again
and to representative long I I don't
know who would have represented somebody
but I had someone that didn't do their
laidac and you know they they kept
telling me they would but it's like six
months a year to get them not only the
cost and so they went online and got one
and it was uh someone that had I think
they I don't know if it's a PhD or it's
a it's a higher level I'm not sure
exactly it's a mental health degree
um and they were able to get it online
and I was impressed that it was thorough
but again it was
um you know two thousand dollars out of
their pocket so
I don't think courts are over
recommending it in my experience it's
always beneficial because I think that
you can see what basically we're looking
for untreated things are you treating
you know you we take people as they are
but are you doing the best so that you
can have the parenting skills you need
to keep a child safe and meet their
needs
thank you representative Macbeth
um
I
I need committee's help
we are living in a world
um
where
there there is a great deal of
Misfortune a great deal of of tension a
great deal of
um of concern and
the the the
arena is huge
but here we are
trying to look just at
the family court
can't possibly solve
all the problems
that that families
are experiencing across the country
um
and yet just in the examples that we've
talked about
we have the family court we have dcyf we
have Health and Human Services we have
the police
um
we have uh trained professionals I mean
all of these people outside of the Court
um
certainly the Court's decisions can't
make everyone happy
although by and large
they do
managed to um
manage the majority of cases not all the
cases by any means but certainly the
majority of cases
um
we will never
we could struggle to create a more
perfect union but we're not likely to
achieve that
so what I want
help with is what can we focus on
that involves the family court
where we can focus our energy and part
of that might very well be to make clear
that it isn't the family Court's
responsibility to act as if they would
dcyf for example or as if they were
um uh
the drug
institutions it attempts to you know
address drug issues
um
they have to engage obviously with all
these other factors in the society but
what can we focus on
it's the family court where their piece
of the action so to speak
is given all the due regard that it
deserves and the support
that it
um
that the state is obliged to provide
because we have
an obligation
representative ball and then represents
caught up
thank you chairman uh chairwoman I'm
sorry it's okay
um I respectfully agree with everything
that you just stated and I
humbly put forward the recommendation
that we start
um in the middle
kind of where everything is going right
and we have two fit parents and we take
the lead of six other states that have
put forward equal parenting
um and we look at that as a serious way
of addressing at least that portion
everything else that starts moving to
the outskirts has to be dealt with but
we need to start with the presumption
that we're going to have 50 50 parenting
when both parents are fit parents and I
think that would help alleviate a lot of
the animosities that tends to come into
the courtroom when people are very
afraid of losing their children access
to their children but um respectfully I
I would love to see a start at a center
point and then start moving away but I
do agree with you that the family court
is responsible
um for that portion and the other thing
should be moved out to other agencies
thank you thank you
we do now have 50 50 parenting is what
where we start at
Marissa actually we have a try to make
it as equal as possible and but it is
not necessarily 50 50 and my experience
has been
um
that in some courts it happens and in
other courts it does not but it is not a
guarantee that we start with a
presumption of 50 50.
so I actually asked that when we were in
the Nashua Court specifically directly
to the judges and they did state that
typically they try and they consider
what's in the best interest of the child
and if you look at what the RSA is and
they specifically said that they do not
start with a presumption of 50 50 and
this is directly from three judges at
the Nashua court so if you look at the
RSA it says in determining parental
rights and responsibilities the the
court shall be guided by the best
interests of the child and when it goes
into its it does say that like each
parent
um
shall have contact with they should
promote allowing contact with each
parent but it doesn't say anything about
equal so I do think that there is a key
difference in actually a presumption of
equal Parenting Time versus just
continued contact with each parent you
know like an actual are we going to try
and as reasonably as possible do 50 50
verse is it just
time with each parent I think there's a
huge difference between that
so I think that you're what when I go
are you finished
you should think I stand corrected what
I what I think is I tell my I think what
the court is is both parents are equally
considered for being their parenting it
doesn't start off so I think that you're
right when the judges said no we don't
start off at 50 50. we start with a flat
flat slate and then we go but there's
not a a bias that it should be anything
but I I do think the presumption is both
parents start out as equally fit to be
parents so I think I probably overstated
the 50 50 but
representative Greg
so that's one of those complications
that we've talked oh sorry thank you
madam chairman I always appreciate you
sorry if you forget to say it
um you know it's one of those things
we've talked about a lot in children and
family law because
um it's it's something that certainly
comes up the the dilemmas that we
continue to hit is for a hundred
families we have a hundred fluid
situations
so to say that we're going to start with
having this particular part of the
puzzle we're going to try to throw
everybody in this
is complicated especially when there are
so many things underlying in situations
um you know I'm going to go back to
abusive situations because we do have a
high population that have domestic
violence in our particular State and so
you know when you go into things like
that to say we're going to start with
this
leads to a lot of different things we've
heard from you know Waypoint we've heard
from other things that that will
actually keep some
domestic violence victims in their
situation thinking that well if this is
on the books that it's 50 50 immediately
and by the way I I've not come across
one Survivor that doesn't think that you
know they're going to lose their kids
because they've been told that the
entire time as soon as you go or that
doesn't think I'm managing this at home
right now as soon as they the other
person can have the child without
supervision what that does so that's
just one complication representative
long has brought up a really good point
too when we start 50 50 what what does
that look like equal parenting you know
a lot of times the court says okay well
it makes sense for them to be with you
know one parent during the week because
you know they're at school this is you
know their routine and stuff so what
would that look like 50 50 like three
and a half days and all of a sudden they
split it's just a it's one of those
things that I think it sounds really
good and we want parents especially well
parents to have as much visitation as
possible and I understand the reason to
say it is because there are parents who
have not had any contact but saying
automatically like we have to do equal
parenting mainly doesn't work in
actuality because then you've got a
parent that maybe goes to work at five
in the morning so what does that mean
the child has to get up because it's 50
50 we have to have 50 50 then that child
gets up it's just complicated like it's
one of those things that I think by
fixing a few situations we can make a
massive
um
uh we would we would regress on other
situations because it because it sets
set up there so it's just very
complicated to put something that black
and white on the books
representative
thank you so I wanted to kind of go
through like a list of ideas that I had
and I do want to circling back to the 50
50 custody thing I do think that if the
presumption was that it was going to be
50 50 unless the parents agreed
otherwise I do think that there are a
multitude of different situations and
there would be parents that would come
into it with an open mind that okay we
need to do what's best for our kiddos
because we know that the presumption is
going to be equal parenting time but I
have you know an a
a 3 to 11 shift and the other parent has
some other shift I think that they would
come up to what works and makes sense
for their own family I really think that
there would be more people that would
come together to figure out what would
work for their family if it wasn't so
much of just fighting to get any time
but it was okay we're so we're gonna
have equal time how can we actually make
this work with our work schedules so I
do think a presumption of equal time
would actually lead to the parents
working through things more I also think
um if the child support were to be fixed
that that would be really helpful right
now there can't be like any kind of the
guidelines are not really
in a way that's workable so I think if
if if one parent is being ordered to pay
more you can't just because there's more
parenting time even with another parent
it doesn't mean that that other parent
has to pay less I think to me what would
be fair is when you do up these child
support worksheets if Say What You Know
parent a it says the cost to raise a
child is three thousand dollars and
parent B the cost to raise a child is
one thousand dollars you take the
difference and you split it in half so
that means that each parent is now going
to have two thousand dollars to raise
the child
if you just take the difference and you
say Okay parent a is three thousand
parent B is 1000 and you take the two
thousand then you've got parent B having
three thousand in parent a now only has
one thousand so I think we do need to
consider those guidelines I think
um also we sh another area that we
should really take a look at is
timelines so we have timelines for some
things and not timelines for others and
I think if we had a more clear picture
of of having timelines for things
it would be better I know we just
expanded under SB 180 is it 189 or 129
um mediation for those who can't afford
it
um and I do think if we had kind of some
better timelines in place
we might be able to work through things
the other thing that might be nice for
us to look into a little bit is is
expanding the neutral case evaluation I
know that's currently only offered in
Concord I think if it were offered a bit
in a bit wider net again like I think
nobody knows what's best for your family
than your own family you know what's
what your children do what activities
that you have what schedules that the
parents have and so if they knew like
hey
if if you're going to go to court then
the the judge is going to decide and
nobody's going to be a winner because he
doesn't know all these intricate details
of your family let's try and work this
out and you've kind of got the neutral
case evaluator saying well if you go to
court like no you're not going to get
your whole list and you're not going to
get it either and it might be bits and
pieces that weren't even priorities for
either of you so let's just try and work
it out together so I think you know that
is one piece that I'd also like to look
into
um and then I'd also within the the
timelines as well like kind of circling
back with that like I think if there
were if we did go back to that one judge
one family that it really would
help a lot I think where the timelines
are so spread out right now where you
know we've got some things that are
required to be done with a certain
amount of time and then some that just
have no end date in sight that
judges are retiring or moving on to
another office and then we've got a new
judge coming in that is completely
unfamiliar with what's going on with the
case and
trying to read back through think about
some of these families have gone in from
motion after motion hearing after
hearing to try and read through all that
testimony and whatnot it's just not
efficient for a judge to have to kind of
read reread through all that so those
would kind of really be my key areas
that I would like to suggest
thank you let me ask you a question
about this
um one judge one family
one of the issues that
I
heard again and again as we listened to
Witnesses was what seemed to me to be
um
a confusion
between
um
the domestic violence issues
and those other issues that get you into
Family Court we had people testifying
who expressed their distress
um about
uh
a decision that a judge made and then
I realized it had nothing to do with the
divorce proceedings it had to do with
domestic violence and that the primary
participants
didn't seem to understand the concept of
the difference
and jurisdiction and in responsibility
between those two Avenues of the
components of the judicial system
so when you have
um a particular family with issues of
custody issues of
of uh parenting issues of domestic
violence
who's the lead judge and what is the um
uh the determination about who
follows
given also the fact that the judges act
not necessarily regularly but certainly
do act as if they were circuit judges
and so they moved from one Court to
another
um
so the ideal might be one judge
one family
but can that work in order for that to
work in practice
do we have to change
by legislative action or do the courts
have to change by judicial action
the way
um cases are assigned the way judges are
assigned
how do we how do we find our way into
that gordian knot
so I hear what you're saying
representative and I think
in theory
it's terrific
but is it workable
so while we did hear about a lot of
domestic violence cases here I think
that the percentage that we heard from
relating to is is much higher than what
is actually in the court so I'm going to
look to you if you remember off the top
of your head attorney Pratt but I
believe we were told that there was
roughly 30 000 divorce cases per year
I'm pretty sure it's roughly 30 000 and
the number of divorce the domestic
violence and stalking petitions that are
filed per year
is just shy of um six thousand and so
even if all of those 6 000 were part of
these thirty thousand divorce cases
that's 20 and realistically not all of
these are obviously part of divorce
cases some of these are people that were
not married and do not have children so
while we did hear a great portion in
here I think it's important to note that
the majority of the cases don't involve
domestic violence
in them and I that and so from that
perspective I just I do want to caution
us on not although we've we've heard
from a high percentage in this
particular committee I do want to
caution that I don't think that that's
the general percentage and you may know
better Macbeth
actually I had a question for you uh
representative catawb so what percentage
of cases are not one case one judge
because we've heard that here but again
that isn't my experience my experience
is the reason we have a different judge
is because someone comes in with an
emergency motion generally they are but
I don't represent it I don't so do you
have do you have statistics on how many
people don't have one judge are we
talking about the people that we've the
witnesses we've heard from here
certainly we've heard that here and I
have two I'm not challenging that so I
asked for some of that data there's a
little bit of trouble with getting some
of the data because some of the data
they just don't have I did reach out to
a few different family law attorneys
that just are are friends of friends
um and they did tell me that they've had
quite a bit of turn off with going from
with judges switching different
um locations and with getting different
judges they said that they would say
even in about half of their cases
they've ended up with a with a different
judge pretty high percentage I don't
know if you've maybe lucked out in one
area where they didn't or and I'm
wondering so I think that's that's very
interesting so I think it'd be
interesting to know if these um the why
judges changed were they moved by the
court because I know they reassigned or
did they retire or or or was it just
that's not the priority of that area and
it would might also be interesting to
know which areas are having problems
with that because we they are
um you know they're very close to the
ground so they're very sensitive to
what's their neighborhood their
community so it would be interesting to
know if there are certain you know if
it's not happening in some places
and how do we how do we change it is it
more judges I mean we we talked to a
judge and they're you know they don't
have any writing time you know they're
it's it's so you know for for them to
get off the bench to rule on some cases
you know if they're scheduled for things
I mean it's just interesting how busy
they are I don't know if you talk to
your judges so is in order to have one
job the one judge one case is it that we
need to have the judges in the court
house more time so that that judge is
available when that case comes forward
because that's generally my experience I
have had cases that have had but
generally it's when we didn't want to
wait for them to get off vacation or you
know or what something like that but
the questions that you asked in the
Family Division
um in 22 2022 they had
7054 divorce and parenting cases
they had 3860
domestic violence cases
um then you know the the juvenile
delinquency chins cases abuse and
neglect
um
uh guardianship of minors
and the termination of parental rights
the termination of parental rights is uh
um
which
would clearly indicate that that is a
that that that's a few
cases of the most difficult and that are
the most difficult
um
but
one of the things that struck me is
while
the budget that we just passed provides
significant additional money
for the courts that nonetheless
um the uh the courts have
um I think it's close to Ford or about
40 positions now that are unfilled
so
um
if if those positions alone were
unfilled without the additional money
it would make a significant difference
um
and certainly with the additional money
it might mean that
um
that some of the problems will have been
addressed
I want to go back to something about
training
and supervision
and accountability
um
the training that is offered uh
is once a year there's access to very
solid National Training
um
but when you look at the judges who are
appointed
almost none
have had experience in the family court
they have had experience in other
other in other courts Perhaps Perhaps
not some people get appointed having had
no experience in any courts at all
because most of the work that lawyers do
doesn't involve courts although we don't
think of that because we just think of
how things are shown on television
um
so you get somebody who has no
experience with family court we all know
how we struggle with how complex the
laws are how they change
how they're interpreted
um uh
if they have a a week
of training
and then there
dropped in a court with a long
caseload
what do we expect
I mean
what what do we expect of somebody who's
dropped in an alien culture and doesn't
speak the language
uh and
that is something that is a real concern
to me
the executive branch is the branch
that's involved
in the appointment and we haven't talked
about the executive Branch's role in
this at all but that is obviously
they're at the Starting Gate they they
are at the Starting Gate for who in fact
sits on the bench
and then we put these
Earnest capable
committed people in the court
who who don't speak the language
what do we do then how do we train them
how to how do we provide
supervision how do we provide
accountability uh
that whole piece is something that to me
is very important did I see your hand
represented long because you're more
knowledgeable than I am about this no I
I actually that is one of the questions
thank you madam chair that is one of the
questions I ask
um
um you know and I saw the two people
that I've asked the question two faces
get uncomfortable uh because I said that
it you know is at political appointments
is that the issue you know I'm just
trying to get to the bottom line of why
this is all happening
um
there is training by a for a week
by a National Association somewhere in
the country okay
um if they all could make it so
they they don't all make it uh so so
that was one of the issues um but but
with all this discussion
what I look for is
um a reducing Conflict for example the
presumption of equal parenting that'll
clearly reduce conflict because I'm not
fighting to see my child to how much I'm
not gonna pay you know I mean is is it
complicated absolutely is because I
could see people fighting over yeah I
want equal parenting because I'm going
to pay less
right uh it's not you know we hear we
heard a lot of testimony
um that they felt like winners or losers
you know and we got to turn that into
the child you know is the child the
winner or loser so reducing conflict
when I had children of family law when I
look at a bill I look for that I look to
see if this will reduce or add conflict
um
so these are all equal parenting is
great
um you know the the timeline I think is
is fantastic knowing that
you know my ex can't drag this on
forever
you know I gotta stop paying for an
attorney and go pro se
um I I'd like the neutral case
evaluation
uh everything we do is going to be
complicated you know but we need to do
something and then work on you know
because these the conflict cases are
are smaller than you know there's I
don't know 70 percent of the cases that
come through where you could get in
agreement with both parties uh is
what I remember
um you know so then you address the the
complicated cases I remember judge uh
Foley coming before Children and
Families saying
whenever I get a uh a conflict case
I said what I said with the two parties
and I say
um you do realize that because you can't
agree on something I'm gonna have to
make that choice and want to use not
gonna like that choice
you know and I thought that that was
good you know the more
parents could get together with the best
interests of the child and not
one-up each other
you know that's that's what we look for
um and I and I think all of these in
some form need need to be uh you know
need to needs to come to the surface and
then work on addressing the
complications
um
uh
yeah you know and the same with
supervised visitation I I think
representative Macbeth said it best that
these supervised visitations are
testimony that we heard of parents not
seeing their child for a year or two
years six months
why because
they had a Dewey and the other parents
saying when I drop them off he looks
like he's drunk so as a judge and you
know you're thinking okay that's a
liability for me if I allow that child
to visit
knowing that the person is an active
Drinker
um so these supervised visitations
during that period where they're trying
to figure that stuff out
this is where these are used you know so
they don't
so they don't stop for a year or two
years or longer
so I think everything that has been
brought to the table
um
is quite a bit for the summer friends to
be working on I just I just also wanted
to say uh the staff issue I I was blown
away by visiting Laconia I was blown
away by the lack of employees you know I
mean the seven judges may help
but you know they're staff workers
they're making 16 an hour with Stacks
and stacks of cases that they gotta
review type up
I'm like how does this happen so so I
could see a bottleneck
um that complicates that creates more
conflict I think
um so you know a serious look at
the financial standings of the judicial
system of the Family Division anyways
representative
I'm sorry one issue that is dovetails
into this but that I really see
significant is the number and the
increasing number of pro se parties and
that ties in also I think with the lack
of staff at the window to provide
adequate
um again they're not allowed to provide
legal that's what I know but but just
that they're not so overwhelmed that
they can't provide the forms or the list
I know that the courts we saw they have
you know really good this is these are
the forms you need you know you need to
feel these out but you know a financial
affidavit is fairly hard to fill out if
you don't have some support and I'm not
sure that we have the staff that can
really provide
um the support that may be necessary for
the amount of pro se people we have one
thing that I'm shocked about and I think
there was some we had provided some
testimony and one of one of the
witnesses they had been defaulted on an
issue and they kept trying to go back
they were so upset about it but I think
also Pro Se people don't realize that
it's not the doctor's office you don't
call up and say the day before two days
before I want to change the state or I
don't feel well I'm not coming in I mean
if you don't show up at court you you
can be defaulted and if you are that
that issue has been resolved and we do
that to protect our courts from having
people just come back and come back and
come back and again that's a small thing
but I think managing the expectation and
the needs of our citizens that are pro
se is important and I think that also
protects our judges because I think
people have testified well there's this
law and it would have changed my child
support or changed my parent but it's
not for the judge to bring it forward
and when that individual has showed me
what they've done they've never brought
forward there is a statute you know we
have a statute that would have changed
their child support or would have
changed their maybe their parenting
responsibilities but they didn't bring
it forward and it you know we can't so
we do need training the training for the
judges it's completely but I'm going
back to the number of pro se people we
have how to manage their expectation
educate them appropriately I think the
neutral case evaluation is critical
mediation as I understand it it's what I
like when I'm in a case is somebody to
tell me this is what's fair you know a
neutral person mediation really is just
getting people to agree the mediator
isn't supposed to give a lot of dialogue
on this is fair or this is what the
court of this is you know this is how
the case has come out they're really
just supposed to get you to yes I mean
again I know it's too simplified but
that's why the neutral case evaluation
is so good because they can actually say
you know what this I think you know here
uh the you're at zero and you need to
get over here to some you know five or
six or and and that's really some
mediators do do that but as I understand
it really they're supposed to get you to
Yes
um which you know is and I'm not
belittling that it is still very good to
get people to yes because some people
are reasonable and they expectations and
that might work in a lot of cases but
when you have somebody that really isn't
reasonable then they're not it's not for
the mediator to tell them you know Bob
that's not going to go I mean that's
what I understand anyway Pro Se people
really concern me judges being there
that want to and that are trained and
pro se people having the information and
the staff they need to give them
information so the Staffing isn't is an
issue and the dependence in the courts
on uh or the prevalence of pro se
um
individuals uh does create problems I
know in the cases we observed in Concord
last week
there was an attorney only I think in
one in one case
um and and that was all
um
I also was surprised to learn that there
are about a dozen different forms
um having to do with divorce
legal separation petitions with minor
children
um parenting
and
um
they're complicated
and
it is my understanding that at least
some of those forms come from
legislative action is that correct
representative wall
uh I don't believe so I believe it's the
courts that
make those ones I I don't recall ever
oops I'm sorry
yeah I don't recall ever voting on a
ever having a bill of a forum coming in
before okay so not the child's not any
of the child support
excuse me
um yeah well I know I know we did form
formulas but as far as the form was left
okay so it would be the form of the UN
underlying principles right that then
are applied by the court right
um uh
excuse me
yeah that's
that's what I'm I'm curious about that
in fact that you know
how much of those forms are based on any
rsas and I'm not embarrassed to say I
don't know I mean because
we all know just a tiny bit of all this
it's so complicated
um I did hear a comment from one of the
clerks that I thought was quite
interesting having to do with
um the financial forms
and the comment was that the forms all
had to do with income
money coming in from whatever source
but none of the forms addressed the
costs
um particular to that family of raising
a child whether there are specific costs
that aren't covered by health insurance
for example or whether the child is you
know going to be an Olympic skier and
whatever but are those costs in some
ways
born more by one party or another based
on
when the child is with
that party and
that
occurred to me that it it that might be
a legitimate question
um
and that's why I want to know whether
what role the legislature
plays
um in that and I'm sure people who are
more knowledgeable than I am would know
the answer to that
so I just want to respond that the
financial affidavit in the Family Court
the third page is all what that fan that
parent and that household's costs are
and that is why I have asked for it from
some of the people that have asked for
the child support guidelines to be
changed for different reasons because
judges look at that and they they do
determine whether they're going to
deviate if you've asked for a deviation
based on the maybe extraordinary housing
costs some parent has or uninsured
Health that type of thing so I don't I
just want to say I do think the judicial
brand you're not saying they don't but
that that form is that's definitely
there and it's definitely why I've asked
for it from folks and as of yet I
haven't gotten it from that gentleman
but
um that is what judges do look at and
one reason why I think our guidelines
are good I don't I'm not sure
specifically what the guidelines want to
change but we do give judges the
um
the discretion to look at that and also
to look at is somebody voluntarily
putting one-third of their income into
retirement or some type
you know so we can double check but I I
that is there and one of the things that
happens with Pro Se I mean that form is
supposed to be submitted at every family
hearing it's supposed to be updated and
submitted at every family hearing and
that's another thing about expectations
I think if you're Pro Se I mean the
rules are difficult for me and I haven't
gone to a hearing that I haven't
accidentally missed something but when
that isn't provided every time then we
don't have the full information but
but
representative McMahon I don't want to
put you on the spot but I wonder if you
I'm interested in your
what your thinking is if you have
anything that you want to share now you
might not
um about where you would like to see us
go I just value your opinion do you want
to open that door
um I am I hope I'm honorable but I don't
deserve the title your honor
here
um and listening to my colleagues and
also uh what's going through the
database that I have myself
um on the meetings that we've taken
um one issue and hearing today there's a
a process that we've learned here again
specific to Family Court
and is where have violations of the
quote process or the interpretation of
process uh taking place and then need
the dressing and one of them was Rules
of Evidence and what has come in my view
of this is something for us to consider
and work on
was uh when when a court case comes
before the
the Battleground if you will uh then
it's uh are each uh
defendant and uh petitioner
are they fully loaded with with evidence
and when the job when I've seen and
tested seen read and heard in testimony
is that uh judges have a specific
interpretive
uh intent of what they consider
legitimate or not which is an opinion
and not based on law but whether they
what they consider as as evidence or
something that is pertinent to the
adjudication of the of the action in
place and so and so what I saw here in
this was that the a rules rules of
evidence
need to be need to be addressed as part
of enhancing the family court experience
based on what has been discussed here is
that it's um not uh followed and it's
interesting we just had something else
passed to us right now and it's and it
says right in here it says uh
um you'll see it on page four of nine
it happened January of 2023 and this
fourth proceeding where it says the
court does when I say the court I don't
know who wrote this whether it's a clerk
or the judge him or herself but it says
Rules of Evidence are not technically or
strictly applicable
and the court const when they're cooked
in schools a motion for reconsideration
that's what's Happening Here
that's when I have learned uh in my
perception and curious what other
members feel is when the petitioners
do not feel they're being heard is
because evidence is not being not
allowed to be presented or if it is
allowed it can be just discounted based
on the opinion of of the Court the court
meaning the judge
uh in the in the promulgation of the of
the court case itself
so that's that's what I
that's what I've learned on all this and
then what happens when there's the when
you want to the playing field that your
your evidence will be heard
then we go in go into then what takes
place on action uh like oatmeal
co-parenting and so on based on what's
the evidence before I decide on
co-parenting not that there's a de facto
uh predetermined result it's what's the
evidence that then says okay to 50 50.
to me that makes intrinsic sense but but
it's based on what
and uh when what's just interesting when
I see evidence is not does not play a
role
but then and then when uh compounded by
professional attorneys also can afford
them versus Pro Se and that's uh I went
to the the team of us went to the
National court system and out of the
five has either five cases on a five out
of six one didn't show up but five
um four were per se and one had an
attorney and and the only attorney was
doing was observing uh what I saw it was
sitting at the table but it was a judge
asking you know directly the but the um
the individual
but but anyway my point The Madam chair
was uh Rules of Evidence playing a role
in what I um and as representative
uh
is obviously representative stated was
that what we recommend as uh laws to be
passed
as to consider for you know for the
court system
not not saying what the rules are but
what's the law to to for the for us as
representatives to recommend for Passage
through the I would imagine the
Judiciary Committee
well
for that comment so the issue of Rules
of Evidence we did hear a lot about
um uh from people who have testified and
what to me came was most clear and and
in a way I think you know you supported
that is that
um pro se litigants
don't understand
the role that Rules of Evidence could or
should
play in in court procedures and what are
the rules of evidence I mean it's not as
if it's the Ten Commandments and even
then we have differences of opinion we
certainly have differences of opinion on
what Rules of Evidence are and so the
question that that you raise I think is
a legitimate question and the answer
might be very complicated or it might be
as simple as finding a way to have a
uh Pro Se uh litigants understand the
roles of Rules of Evidence or it might
be something much more specific than
that so I think that certainly is a
legitimate issue
having been raised a lot
in our hearings to go on our list of
things we might want to look into yes I
mean thank you for adding that well
Madam chair that's your guidance on on
this one on and and any other uh esteem
members is uh and that's I want to make
sure I say it in my context
there's been there has been comments of
implication that the the judges
themselves
aren't competent
and and making their decisions and this
is where you get to the training not and
confident in terms of dealing in the
uniqueness of in the Family Court uh as
opposed to a criminal case we haven't
dealing with family issues and and you
know it will stipulate what what we've
heard already
um is there uh
from a training standpoint
is that is that something no that's
something that's come up here that we
should make also part of law that has
been suggested here for those uh and
then the enhanced uh how they're paid as
well for folks to take on these cases
which uh
there's as we said there's hundreds
thousands of them
but who's willing to take on to who's
like a judge in the system and the staff
by the way you have the staff there that
really does a heck of a job
uh along with the judge's work on
meeting these these uh these Court
challenges and if we don't have the
resources
then that what I've been reading when
I've been reading what we've been
provided is that there appears to be a
facilitation to move things faster
through
so that the cases are handled quicker
and not necessarily to the best interest
of either party
uh um I hear what you're saying and I'm
sure there are people who who believe
that just as I'm sure they're people who
believe
um contrary to that
um you know this
it isn't we're a litigious country and
these systems are adversarial we would
like not to see them adversarial when
they involve children in the well-being
of families but
um we tend to set things up with winners
and losers and and all those things that
make it hard to just be nice to
everybody
but we also have to I think remember
that the people who have been diligent
in coming to speak before us
um
are uh are
very distressed very very distressed
about what their experiences have been
and we also have to remember that as
important as their experiences are and
we don't want to minimize that they also
um are a very small minority
of all of the cases that are heard and
um
that go through and people are
reasonably satisfied understanding that
the world isn't perfect so we also have
to be careful not to be swayed by
um
information that might be taken out of
context but I go back again to the one
of my major concerns and that is
recruitment training supervision and
accountability and some of that is the
responsibility of the executive branch
so if it's the responsibility of the
legislative and some of it's the
responsibility of the judicial branch
and how this committee handles that I
don't know but
um
that's why I'm so pleased that chairman
Pearson who was very sorry that he
couldn't be here today but is involved
in other
important business out of state
agreed that this session would be a work
session so that before we go into the
summer recess we could begin to identify
Myriad issues that we'd like to look at
more deeply and
and I think you raised some some
important some important issues and uh
how we
determine what is in fact the
legislative responsibility or the
responsibility of one of the other
branches is going to be Central to this
representative bull
thank you madam chairman
um the one thing and I do agree with
everything that you're saying
um the one observation a couple actually
a couple of observation we had some very
brave people come to testify before us
but I do believe there are a lot of
other families out there that are
struggling but they do not want to bring
their case forwards because they're
afraid there could be a retaliation or
it be used against them if they have to
go back to court so they're trying to
keep it a private matter that would be
one the other is when we talk about
domestic violence I think that we need
to be sure that we're separating how
many cases were actually dropped and how
many are actually convicted I think
unfortunately
people involved in this can become very
emotional and they can be somewhat I
hate to use the word unscrupulous but
they will use the court in order to get
what they want against another parent
and I'm afraid that that tends to be
um
a little easy to do and in the system
and I'm not saying it happens a lot I'm
just saying that it there is a means for
that to happen and I I think we need to
somehow figure out how to close that
loophole
um one of the things that was brought up
when we went to the Nashua court and I
was quite shocked by is two of the cases
that we listened to
both
um times the children were allowed to be
taken out of state
um but there didn't and in both cases
there didn't seem to be a mechanism to
get them back into the state for
visitations and I I was confused by that
and and very concerned
um that that was happening and I'm sure
there was a reason for it but I do think
that's something that also if we are
going to allow children out of state we
do need to make sure we're setting up a
way so that the parent who is still here
is not incurring Financial hardships in
order to try and get visitation with
their children thank you
representative
um I have a question from my colleague
um representative McMahon when people
are bringing or your own interest in
having the Rules of Evidence in the
Family Court are they specifically
mentioning which rules they feel are are
not adequately applied
uh no weapons
not that I on the reading I've done and
the observations uh don't even asked
that's a question on that there's not
been a specificity it's just the the
global statement that Rules of Evidence
are not applicable in Family Court
so I'm wondering and of course chair
Pierre would be personal part that one
might be a good role play for us
um to be in court and see if we being
pro se
um could get a document in like a
screenshot of uh your partner saying I
don't care I'm going to drive them drunk
because uh it doesn't matter because you
don't you know I I can do whatever I
want and I'm driving I'm driving so you
know if you had that screenshot and you
brought it into court I would be
surprised if we had the Rules of
Evidence in in effect if a pro se person
would be able to easily authenticate
that document and get it accepted what
we have now with the Rules of Evidence
don't don't strictly apply they do apply
I mean I I it's amazing because
generally they are applying but not in
the strictest sense but if you had that
screenshot the judge might if they want
you could say do you do you recognize
this does this a text you did is this
you know is this something you know do
you uh do you uh you know authenticated
that way instead of having to either
have you know phone records or
certification or just the whole line of
questioning you know have time and date
so I think we heard from some some of
the judicial some of the officers saying
that I do it so people can get stuff
like that in so that's why I'm wondering
what rules you know are people upset
about the other thing is when you you
know if you hearsay I mean can you not
say you know my 10 year old told me you
know her mother put an iron on her you
know well no you can't because that you
know what I mean that's the Rules of
Evidence are going to apply that's you
know hearsay you can't bring it in so I
think that's why we in New Hampshire
have allowed them to be lacks not
strictly or technically applied because
they do apply but I I really that's why
I'm wondering what what rules
all of them or some of them and what
would really be the impact and I know
that for me it as a practitioner I I
don't get stuff in because I don't know
the rules well enough of evidence
sometimes
um so
um I'm just I would be concerned with
the amount of pro se people we have but
if you if people are specifically
talking about certain rules that they
have a problem with I would like to know
that and that would be helpful I think
and that also goes back to maybe
educating people that are pro se in the
front end you know this is you know
you're going to be held to this level of
performance or you're not going to be
able to bring in stuff that
um you know so you can't bring in a
doctor's report that's just a copy of
what they've given you you know that
that's not going to be okay can't bring
in attendance forever that's just a copy
I mean you'd have to if the Rules of
Evidence applied you know it's got to be
authenticated properly a proper
Foundation laid
so
excuse me
excuse me thank you
okay go I'll if I may offer something to
that uh I'll uh I understand what you're
saying as part of the uh considered part
of our narrative that we've heard here
as our committee and one thing I've
learned here before getting to where the
the judge is making this uh decisions on
what has been heard we have the two
other two other avenues which is you
know mediation and then the new one that
I've learned I think with other members
was the neutral case evaluation uh
alternative before or hopefully not
needing to go to the authority having
jurisdiction being the judge
but notwithstanding uh that Avenue and
where and that's where Pro Se I would
say has much more influence
um because they're on an even playing
field you know in terms of trying to
come to a Cooperative collaboration to
achieve consensus but before the uh
going before uh before the the judge it
was
been uh and I'm not in front I'm in
front of the judge I'll stipulate that
that has not been the case I'm happy to
tell you but the uh fact is it's either
you're a dog or a cat and do you do the
Rules of Evidence allowed the answer is
no by allowed meaning they're not a
pursuant to family court cases and
should we and when I'm suggesting we
consider in our discussions cross that
bridge to say Rules of Evidence shall
apply and here what they here's what the
Rules of Evidence specifically are so
there's no misinterpretation of intent
and that's just what I've that's what
I've known here when and then to hear
this case we're just going to cop copy
of that says it doesn't apply
and uh and so if I go in there am I
fully armed in my particular case or is
it based on if the if the authority uh
likes me that day or did I tell the
right word that day not dealing with
evidence but how I present the case one
on either side on on in Family Court
and that's why I find to be to be uh of
how do you um not level the playing
field but can we get on the field with
the equal access to the tools
to advance my the positions
representative
so
um following up on that I think one of
the things that we did here regarding
the Rules of Evidence
um
was really people wanting to have the
discovery regulations enforced so that
somebody couldn't spring evidence on
somebody that they hadn't previously
seen and it seemed like
and I did actually hear this and I I
don't know Macbeth if you've experienced
this but I've heard from some attorneys
as well that you know sometimes the
judges are are very strict on
that you needed to meet the timeline to
to give your Discovery but then
sometimes they're more lacks about it
where if it was due 10 days before and
you gave it the day before
um
you're going to be in trouble for that
verse sometimes they just ignore it and
it depends on the the day it's not even
necessarily the judge
um have you experienced that because I
that is something that I also heard as
well like with an issue
I don't I don't think I've experienced
that wild swing but I think that's I've
heard complaints about from testimony
people not being allowed to provide
their you know make their argument or
whatever they were cut off by the judge
but they didn't bring it before so I
mean what's the what's the and I think
also that's a good thing about one judge
one case I mean if you've got they've
been working together and they know that
this guy's all or This Woman's always a
little bit late you know like I was I'm
always late I don't know what's wrong
and it's this phase of my you know they
may I I mean they have the flexibility
to work with that but no I don't I don't
see the wild swings that
um I think they're pretty consistent and
I think what they generally do is try to
like the parties you know if it's nine
days or the day before they've both done
it like that that one person hasn't had
a none but and you can always if you
know you can always request a
continuance because you haven't been
able to provide that information but you
may not know how to articulate that if
you're Pro Se and you may not also know
that they've got to hold it 10 days
unless you get the other parties are
sent and they you know so there's all
those things and I just want to say I am
going to bring Rules of Evidence I mean
it is it is not a one-pager you know
they might have it at Kinkos at one page
you know the rules of evidence but it
it's
it's a significant document that has
been interpreted by you know practice
and by a case law so
um anyway but I haven't
first representative one we haven't
heard from you in a while and then
representative Greg
I think I'm Madam chair I sold the uh we
we have heard uh specifics on evidence
that wasn't allowed
um however it's hard for myself to
determine why the judge ruled in that
case
um
the fact that judges are interpreting
differently was an issue and that's a
question I asked whether there's any
um Career Training after three years
four years seven years of being a judge
and there isn't any
um and I know in children and family law
for years we've asked judges to attempt
to get on the same page on bills that
we've been hearing and that has really
never come to fruition
um
because we we hear a lot of this that
judge said X and on the same type of
case this
judge said see
um so I
again it's again it's training and
continue continue training
um thank you representative brick
thank you madam chair so you know then
and just sitting here listening you know
I'm contemplating this is so complicated
family case it's even one case is
incredibly complicated but the common
denominator that keeps coming up when we
have issues with cases is the pro se
obviously we can't expect you know this
is why in Criminal Court you know you
have attorneys assigned we can't do that
in family court it's not practical
so I think one of the things we can do
and you know is
you know we can just recommend obviously
we're not the judicial branch Branch I
have a great respect for the judicial
branch and all this work that they have
to do
but um is looking at there and I did not
take the time that day to look down and
if we're pro se we saw the computer
where they can log in and do all the
things to see what that is you know
there are National recommendations on
that kind of stuff like as to for the
court systems as to what you could do as
pro se but there is a certain level of
personal responsibility
um that that we can't fix you know the
pro se because there's a lot of you know
judges are trained years and years and
years if somebody decides they're going
to handle their own divorce case they
maybe looked at Google you know for a
few months or whatever and it's just
very very different but I I from what we
saw the judge was incredibly Fair we saw
a lot of pro se you know very
explanatory as far as okay you can't
present this or you can or you have to
make sure that the other person has this
document too and and even you know
making sure that they have at least a
few minutes to look at it and stuff
um but the pro se is really what we
that's the common denominator is as far
and I could stand corrected on this but
almost every situation it's the pro se
so what we can do is you know maybe make
that recommendation there are certain
things within gal or other things but to
make sure that they have an easy to read
system that's easily accessible you know
where people can look this up and
they're not relying on Google that maybe
has information for other states or
something that we have some direct thing
that they can look at but then we can't
negate personal responsibility once
that's out there but we can take a
better look at what what are we giving
people who are either by choice or by
economics doing the pro se situation and
because that really seems like the
common denominator
so
thank you very much representable
thank you madam chairman
um I do want to just bring up that
attorney had told us that 80 percent of
the cases
um were pro-sag that wasn't here that
was on the children children and family
court so it is quite large
um and it also was brought to our
attention when we were in the Nashua
court that the
courts.newhampshire.gov has
informational videos
that are available to the general public
to go on and learn things legal
definitions what to expect in a court
hearing what is an alternative to
dispute resolution so there's quite an
and access to legal assistance in New
Hampshire so there's quite a bit that
the court does offer the public and it
might just be that perhaps we need to do
a better job in making sure that people
know that this is available to them
thank you very much for that I think
that
um that's a good follow-up of a
representative Greg's comments that the
issue of pro se is really a significant
issue in terms of what works and what
doesn't work in in the family court and
add to that is her additional point that
individuals nonetheless do have a
personal obligation to to do the best
that they can to find the information
that they need when they make the
decision to proceed Pro Se
um I do want to I know that we are
um if you're like me you are drowning in
all of the paperwork that we have
including some that
um I did I looked at my little home
printer and decided that the 385 page
report was not going to be printed out
even though I am so old-fashioned that
to me the only way you should read
something is to have it in your hands I
I just don't like all this all this
electronic stuff
um but and I know that as diligent as
each member of the committee has been
you haven't been able to read everything
but there have been some materials that
have come to us over time that are quite
relevant for example
um Christian Grant had uh has sent to us
something dated June 16th on the
application of the Rules of Evidence in
the Family Division of the circuit core
and it is just a few pages long but
summarizes the major cases that have
been heard over over the years that
demonstrate
um
uh uh
uh how the rules of evidence do or do
not uh relate in in the court and
um
I mean the one paragraph that I just for
the purposes of those who are listening
to today that I would like to read is
trial courts are afforded broad
discretion in divorce matters and we
will not overturn the trial Court's
rulings regarding property settlement
absent and abusive discretion or error
of law to show an abusive distraction
the petitioner must demonstrate that the
Court's ruling was clearly untenable or
unreasonable to the Prejudice of the
case if there is some support in the
record for the trial Court's
determination we will uphold it and I
think that reflects the need to
understand with each case being unique
certainly to the petitioners but also to
all the other cases that there has to be
some flexibility in the application of
the rules of evidence and so I just
point this out as an example of
something of one of many of of the
documents that you have that you'll be
able to spend some time reading it's now
looking at the at the clock I want to
say to you all how very much I
appreciate
the time that you've put in
all these weeks up until now and this
morning and I liked it from now until
the end of this morning session see if
we can identify just a few major
components um
of our discussion that we might want to
do some digging into between now and
September
um representative kotek so if I may
thank you madam chair one I I did break
up kind of what everybody said into two
pages one being legislative changes and
one being possibly like things that we
might be able to work with the with the
court for you know kind of best more
best practices it might be Court things
but not necessarily legislative changes
so I kind of wrote them all down and I
wonder if I can maybe go by topic and we
could say if we do want to move forward
with it and if so like who maybe wants
to work on that would that work sounds
like a great idea okay so the first one
that was raised was gal and the role of
gal and I know that you had raised that
um Greg so I don't if we still want to
look into that if there's those who
might wanna
could could I ask could you read them
all first I'm I'm so visual I mean I'd
like to know what how many I mean or
just give me are there like 12 on each
side or whatever so for legislative
changes this is what I have so the role
of gal
um the neutral case evaluation possible
expansion of it
um Family Law training slash continuing
education for judges
um the presumption of shared parenting
um Child Support guideline fixes
um timelines for cases and then
visitation for at-risk kids and um then
on the court rules side slash best
practices side I have
um looking into potentially staff
helping with forms and pro se parties
um the one judge one family being
enforced
um you had mentioned broadly just kind
of best practice guidelines and and that
being explored and then
Rules of Evidence slash Discovery
regulations
um you know
being enforced and um
more widely available so that's kind of
what I have on both sides of the list
did I miss anything
just looking at the oh sorry can I talk
go ahead thank you madam chair just
looking at that um I don't know if that
falls into the forms or whatever but
kind of looking at the system they have
because there is a national like um
recommendation for uh family courts and
stuff as far as
um what kind of information they help
for like Pro Se litigant so that would
be something I don't guess that would be
a best practices does that fill in with
your are you doing that as part of Staff
helping yeah so that was on the first
thing like with with the forms and the
pro se parties that is on the first
that's the first item on the the court
side of the okay
thank you so one one question I have
about the topics listed and I didn't get
them all written down is some of them
were mentioned here and they are
important policy issues but they're not
to our charge to look at specifically
the Family Division so I think those
things I mean I I actually would kind of
like to look at them all I mean like
reviewing child support guidelines that
is a huge thing and that's not the
that's not the
um family port division that's the
legislation I mean that's policy you
know somewhere beyond that so I'm I'm
not sure well that's this side is
legislative changes so these are like
possible policy changes that we would
make with bells versus more just
recommendations for the court that we
might recommend to them but we're not
going to put this into legislation so I
do agree like this this is the side with
that may be fixed with a bell verse this
is not going to have legislation with it
so could you um so there's seven things
on the legislative side and then there
was four main areas on the Court rule
side so we're looking at like 11 things
here so let's go back to the legislative
forms one judge one case best practice
and what was the fourth Rules of
Evidence okay so slash Discovery
regulations oh yeah okay and the other
list
s um the other list was the gal role the
neutral case evaluation expense
expansion
um Family Law training slash education
slash you know continuing education for
for judges
um the presumption of the equal custody
child support guidelines
timelines for cases and visitation for
at-risk kids
so several of those excuse me several of
those are things like the gal World
expansion events those are really I
would put those on things that we could
talk about because they have to do with
staff and
um
the um and also the role of the GAO
I
anyway I went to a case it doesn't their
parents that really need Guardian items
that are not getting them because they
can't afford them and children that are
in insecure and in stable places because
of that and I think that judges don't
have you know by seeing people I mean
they really do would benefit from that
um
outside of Court you know view so I mean
that's something but again so but things
like child support guidelines I mean we
probably need to narrow that more if
we're talking about legislative but that
that is a big big thing they are big and
I was looking to see like if we want to
take on like some people that want to
talk about some people that want to take
these on so we can kind of out of our
subcommittee like who wants to take on
which piece and I think you know the gal
piece certainly can be legislative
because we did just have legislation
that had passed through our committee it
was a Senate bill but that was giving
the the um
Indigent
um folks access to mediation services
without having to repay them so that can
certainly be something that's added
legislatively legislatively gal wise
that those that that could be paid
um and that could could be something
that's in statute that that is paid so I
do think that that
are you saying that that doesn't belong
on the legislative side I was saying
that's a big issue but I can see when we
break it down underneath there are other
there there are issues that I think the
legislature is the appropriate okay but
but yeah so do we want to go through the
list since people say like which one
they want to be um okay g-a-l
who would like to
not surprisingly representative Greg and
representative long
um have indicated that they really want
to
look in all aspects
of gal
um and here we have to remember that the
reason it's on the legislative side
isn't just policy
um it's dollars
and we had for many years paid for this
and when we stopped paying for it we
um if you think of this as a seesaw
um one person on the end of the Seesaw
fell off
um and so it very definitely is a
legislative
policy the neutral case
hey it probably comes down to some
different problems including people who
would who would carry it out
but I could see it as a legislative
issue if we were
to um in some ways
without violating
the separation of powers recognize the
important role that it could play
is this something that anybody would
like to pers okay
and of course all of us can pursue all
of these in anything else because we'll
come together in the fall and compare
notes and see where we are and what we
want to do and where we're going to go
so none of this is restrictive in any
way so yeah I think I'd like to reserve
and think about it and tell you what I
specifically like
when I when we get to the training
I
I wonder why you put that on the
legislative side rather than on the
judicial side
so I need to think I need to look back
but I and and see if it's on the oplc
side or if it is legislative but I do
know like for for doctors they have a
requirement for continuing medical
education and they can't re-get their
certification unless they've done that
so I would think that there it could be
a same thing for judges where they have
a continuing law training but I do need
to see something so because
um we're looking at the three branches
of government we're looking at the
judicial branch it's a different branch
the legislature does not play a role in
determining who is going to be appointed
to the courts and
um it is
um the judicial Council and other
institutions I would think that are
responsible for the training for
education and certainly for supervision
and accountability
um we do know in cases where judges
um
who have behaved inappropriately have
been removed
they were removed because it was someone
in the judicial branch who uh brought
forward a complaint That Was Then heard
by the judicial conduct committee
enacted on on whatever so I guess
I'd have to be convinced that that
belongs on the legislative side and if
somebody disagrees with me I would I
would welcome the disagreement because
these are all so complicated I moved it
over I agree with you after you've
spoken thank you so representative this
is on the training you moved it back to
the uh the import side so with respect
to uh attorneys having to get
attorneys are not licensed by the
government by the state government
they're licensed and disciplined and
their education requirements are the New
Hampshire Bar Association okay so that's
that's not okay then like Physicians and
nurses I mean they might be the medical
association and they do and the Bar
Association
I think part of the judicial branch it
is not an independent body as it is in
some states so so legislator would only
have say in whether we were going to
elect our judges or nominate an
appointee right however
their qualifications is not in our hands
and and that's right and okay
um
uh I don't think there's anybody on the
Supreme Court now who has ever had any
experience in family core there are some
people on the Supreme Court who haven't
had any experience in court
um there are and in Family Court
judge Marconi had
fall experience baby baby
um
training is on the judicial I would I
would say and and accountability
I mean unless I mean unless the
legislature were to move
to
impeach to charge a judge in the the
house would do and then the Senate to
try the judge
um the legislature would have no
involvement it's the Constitution gives
us that responsibility and in my 25
years that basically happened once
um
uh
and uh so in terms of removal of of a
judge uh generally the judges are who
are removed have been removed through
the judicial conduct committee
I I may just be being defensive for the
profession but I I can't remember which
Governor it was I believe it was 15 or
20 years ago I but whatever government
was did give up considerable political
power when there was established it was
a judge
screening process nomination process low
level and goes through different
committees and then those
recommendations are brought forward to
the executive Council so I'm not saying
that politics politics is plays a part
in everything
um but I I I think that there has been a
more recent a contemporary change to
limit the way politics plays and how and
how or maybe how many people can play
into it but um I I I don't we should
educate ourselves on that we should stay
away from it but
um I don't feel like politics is is a
significant factor in
dissatification the dissatification with
judges that we've or the judicial
decisions that we've been hearing from
thank you representative I haven't heard
anybody suggest that it was politics I
will point out that you're absolutely
right that there was a governor who
insisted that um we use a system more
parallel to what the federal government
does in having a screening process but
um the the incumbent Governor has
changed that and is does not rely on
an independent
um advisory body for nominations it's a
different system uh so um that you know
that does change
um which is not to say that it's
partisan political
um it's just to say that it's a
different system
um okay next
what what are we up to on your list
um the equal slash shared cost
equal shared custody okay now here's my
question what there is a retained bill
on that I know in the family law
committee so I'm not sure if there's
already people assigned to work
with the subcommittee so I would put it
so well so the the Shared Parenting the
Shared Parenting
um
is a policy of the children and family
would go to the children family law
committee so that shouldn't be
on our list
actually they have uh we were just
assigned the people on that are I think
um I don't even see it now now I'm
looking
but I know it's Pearson ball is that the
one we're all in
we're talking about
survive Senate ball who's who's working
on that with you
actually
oh
um our researcher can tell us that
okay so the Shared Parenting is Pearson
ball
Greg
long
and McMahon
okay
one two three okay so that's sheer
parenting and so that I think that
that's handled by children and family
not by us
I believe that that's House Bill 185
yeah so you have long Moulton Levesque
Seidel Bickford Nelson panic
okay next
um so I would move shared parenting if
if everybody agrees that that belongs
with Children and Family
given the existing bill
yes everybody talked about that anybody
uncomfortable with that so I guess I
would say I think they kind of overlap
because I do think it still belongs here
and I know other special committees have
then take kind of taken over a bill and
I'm fine with that bill staying in there
I just think we should keep a watch on
it because I do think it's very
important to what we're doing so I think
I'm okay with them doing it but I think
we should just I think that's a very
good point and I think in in our
summations we should identify this as an
important area that is being pursued by
children and family law does that make
sense to you I was thinking that the
children and family law members of this
committee would be right seeing that
just okay judicial may have other things
okay
um next so regarding the rules I did
actually just pull up RSA 49f colon six
and it does actually have in here that
judges assigned to the family court
shall be subject to the following
considerations the knowledge commitment
to an expertise of the judge in the
subject matter of the particular
division which the judge is assigned so
there are actually there is legislative
statute about requirements for judges so
I don't think that having the training
for the judges is completely out of the
realm of legislation
okay let's see what happens as long as
you have a what is the RSA
490 Dash F colon six F yeah f is in
Frank okay
um so we can we can look into that after
I'll go to I can go on to the next one
so the next one was child support which
I think is going to be the same
situation where we'll watch that bill
because there is a bill in the Family
Court committee that they retained right
children family you have a child support
bill
what we did
okay so then maybe we should maybe we
should look into that separately then
instead of the wage guard let's let's do
that separately
so wage garnishment would be the
children and family law but I think we
should look separately into the area
because I think it's much wider than
just that that would be House Bill 618.
I'm sorry I didn't hear House Bill 618
thank you garnishment so I think we
might need an additional bill in
addition to that so okay yes next
um timelines for cases
okay and we do have statue on some
timelines and then there's some that do
not have any statue associated with it
so I think that that's overall something
that we can look at what does currently
have statue and then
maybe what needs to have statues so that
we're making sure that
you know these cases are resolved within
a certain amount of time or at least
that there's a within a certain amount
of time that there's a uh parenting plan
established that that's making sure that
both both parents can see their children
um
well
I don't know I mean
I think at the moment it's this
committee and then we can you know
there's certainly nothing that I'm aware
of that's in the
Judiciary Committee that would uh deal
with that so I think it's it's it's this
committee um I'm one of the things that
one of the things that I'm interested in
about these timelines issue is
um
I guess comes down to
the process within the judicial branch
where individuals
file a complaint and then file I'm using
the word complaint generically not as a
as a legal term and then file a
complaint and then file a complaint and
then file a complaint and then file a
complaint
um and uh
you do not want to limit the number of
complaints that someone could file if
there's a legitimate reason for somebody
to complain but
what then happens with the timelines
and
and how does that get handled and Who
was Ruth
responsible then for what is
what could be
um
would someone in a bad mood in the
legislature might call dilatory
the issue is what we heard is the um the
docket it's very complicating in the
dockets set up so every time there's for
example we went to a case where that had
the attorney that the other that again
didn't show up so there was 20 minutes
spent there and they had to redo it so
there's another
you know they're looking for another
spot on another docket and setting a
timeline if those timelines aren't met
it's
um it's it's complicated setting up the
docket because you
um you got the docket set up
I don't know a week or two weeks or
longer in advance and trying to fit
somebody in to meet this timeline would
it's what's complicated so I mean I
guess at least especially for ensuring
that a parenting plan is established
within a certain amount of time maybe
the whole case isn't closed but I I
would like to make sure that within some
amount of time we're making sure that
parents are able to see their kids
so
um so I'm agreeing with the conversation
one thing that's making me uncomfortable
though is we're identified issues and I
I don't see these subcommittee groups
going off to find the answer I I'm I'm
wanting them to bring back more
information so that we can then address
them you know so we've if we say
timelines are an issue I don't know that
it's for us to create the timeline it's
to really look are they an issue which
cases
um you know what's already established
why is it what's already established
working do we need to do more and bring
that back
um so I think I think we all agree with
it I don't think anybody's going out and
out of search for the Holy Grail we're
going out to say okay here are areas
that we've identified as problems what
in fact are the problems how do we
Define the problems do we have balanced
information that we're collecting
um uh so that's I think on the one hand
this on the other hand yeah because the
timelines we we may have ideal timelines
but if we can't get the legislature or
if it happens to be Staffing then that's
our issue so I I mean so I will work on
timelines but again I'm not looking at
this as well I think the best I mean I
think the best timeline is today well
you know I have my clients generally say
well why didn't they rule From the Bench
why didn't they tell me today so
um I mean I just hope that everybody is
when we look at shared parenting again
and that's an issue that
um I I don't I I think both parents
should be treated equally but I I want
to know why do you want to establish the
bar why is it best to establish the bar
if you are 50 50 or what does shared
parenting mean that that's going to okay
so I'm just hoping people come back
which has a bill okay all right okay so
timely to fall thank you
um Madam chairman
another bill that we do have is um house
bill
uh
where did I just lose it to
um
oh I think this is one representative
long was referring to House Bill 471
which was establishing the final
disposition for the divorce case and
that goes into the timeline and I think
what people what they were coming
forward and telling us is that
when they went for their temporary
hearing they wanted something scheduled
a year out and put in the docket so that
they would know they were in the queue
because what they were saying is they
would spend lots of time
um
um negotiating with each other and
coming up with an agreement and then
when they went to set the time in the
court it was like a whole another year
away and so that allowed a whole another
year for now things to Bubble Up and now
people are going to go after each other
that was my understanding I could be
wrong but that was something that the um
children and family law was looking at
me thank you
okay what else
um visitation for at-risk kids
um I know that rep blanza had raised out
I'm not sure if you want to work on that
um and then the next are the uh
potentially the court rules so
um
looking at staff and ways to help uh Pro
Se parties with forms
I mean prep Greg and rep McBeth
who said they wanted
Macbeth
um okay the one judge one
the the next one was one judge one
family
I'm happy to help kind of look into that
one does anybody else want to join us to
do that with you
um
best practice guidelines that was
something that you had raised Brett
Macbeth
um and I think I was talking about
coordinating all the different wasn't
best practice for
okay I mean
oh was it I think was it related to Pro
Se because if so I can take that one off
if that's going to be related to the
other one we already have I think
I think we should all be looking at best
practice in whatever area because I
think I was mentioning it we were
talking about police station drop-offs
or
um
even the the guardian ad litems how you
know meshing them making sure they're on
the same page
um
and I think it was also we were talking
about a training as well so yeah I don't
I think that can be removed as far as
any individual
um
okay the next one is Rules of Evidence
slash Discovery
um regulations
and we do have that um June 16th memo
that um
researcher Grant had put together for us
that does explain what the
how the court has the Supreme Court has
um ruled up until now on of course the
legislature could
um involve itself and so there is a bell
rep ball it's raising your hand there's
a bill in fam Court already HP 4.99 and
what is that
House Bill 495 is Rules of Evidence in
the family court and that is in this
Committee in in
commit it's 4.99 you have on there not
4.95. 4.99 yeah 4.99 okay and then in
the children family law okay
um
I mean I think we I would like to look
into that even if it's in children
family mall it's still specifically
related to the functioning of the family
court so I think it so okay
all right and then the final piece is
the family law training slash continuing
ad for judges which
I think can be explored either way
because there is that there is under
statue something now so I do think that
is something that we could potentially
you know look at and see which area we
want to put it into and I'd I would like
to look at that um I would too so me too
okay so that's okay
very good
Madam chairman yes
um also there's I don't know if I
mentioned it um House Bill 475 and that
also has to do with the right to submit
evidence testimony and family court
proceedings and that's also in children
and family law
okay
well clearly there's going to be a lot
of overlap between the work that
children and family law committee is
doing and
um
there's no need for this committee to
reinvent the wheel but the reason that
there are five members from children
family law and five members from
Judiciary is for you know is
demonstrated in in the fact that there
are these bills that are are pending in
children and family law any number of
which bills were part of the impetus to
create this special committee so we want
children and family law to do their due
diligence but they're also clearly
there's a role for this committee to be
involved
um
representative long so uh thank you
madam chair so the timeline is on what
I'm looking at
um I
I wouldn't advise children and family
law to come up with Solutions
that
in this in this committee come up with
different solutions
you know what I mean so what's that
timeline I know we're looking in
September to
um
to start subcommittee work
on our bills yeah according to the email
that I received it was going to be
chairman Pearson myself
representative McMahon representative
Greg and you that we're going on those
particular 475 499 and what 471. okay so
so I'm looking for the timeline as to
when we're going to start discussing
those and children and family law and
what is this committee going to come
with some discussion and suggestions
I'm sorry I was just going to say
according to the email it said the
groups will formally meet in the fall
so I think for us though we can
informally kind of take on some of this
work in the summer to look into stuff
and maybe come up with some solutions to
present to the committee in the fall but
that we're not actually doing any work
because we can't July oh we may or may
not come up with Solutions but we may
come up with
um a clearer
um uh description or definition of the
problem that might need Solutions and
that we shouldn't Begin by assuming that
we know everything there is to know and
that we know
X is right and Y is well wrong because
there's just a lot of complexity in all
of these issues I also know that there
are a number of national
um
institutions which have looked at these
issues have evaluated what's going on in
in different states I know
representative Greg has mentioned
several of them I have looked at some of
them I'm sure some of the rest of you
have also and I would hope that during
the summer
um when you're not sitting in a in a
lounge chair eating chocolate bon bons
and reading mystery stories that you
might want to look at what
what some of the national resources have
suggested about these issues and
recognizing that sometimes a national
suggestion or solution doesn't apply in
New Hampshire we know we we tend to
march to our own drummers sometimes with
good reasons sometimes without good
reason but I don't think we should
assume that we know the outcome now or
at least I would hope that we don't
assume we know the outcome that all we
know is that these are are problems that
that bear
looking into is that is that a fair
assessment
and um of course chairman Pearson's
going to want to
be involved and and exert his leadership
role in this
um but that will not happen until until
the fall
we will
um give him he'll be able to watch this
if he isn't watching it at the moment
um and we'll give him a very detailed
report of what we talked about but
understanding that it's just
um
giving us uh giving us an opportunity to
come back in September and say what we
did with our summer vacation
uh can we Circle back to a few that
didn't really have many people like
working on them and see if anybody else
was interested now that we've gone
through everything so the neutral case
evaluation expansion I was the only one
who had interest on that one does
anybody else want to I'm I'm interested
in that representative Macbeth okay
um so ball and Macbeth
um and then what about child support
because I think that's going to be
another really big one you'd like to
help okay
um and I think everything else oh so the
the child support uh
um I think the only other one that there
was nobody else was the Rules of
Evidence slash Discovery regulations I
know there were some retained Bells
Rhett McBeth you indicated that you'd
also like to be a part of that is there
somebody that's on all of that in
addition
oh rep Greg rep long and yourself okay
I I believe what I heard representative
balls say is that on those bills that
relate to the work here
all of the children and family law
members of this committee are on those
bills
okay
representation
right
um
yeah um
I I we've just been told that the LSR
filing dates are September 11th and 15th
but um I don't that doesn't apply to
this committee's special committees can
um ask the rules committee at any time
uh for bills it does apply if you know
for anybody who on their own want to
come in with uh their own legislation on
these bills
um the bills that are retained have to
be out by November 17th and that would
be about the time that we would want to
have a a final report
anything else for the good of the group
that we should talk about now
um I I really am incredibly
appreciative of all the time that people
have have put into this I think everyone
on this committee has taken it seriously
it's a complicated issue there are no
easy answers
um and uh we will come back in the fall
obviously some of us will will chat
informally
with each other but in no way that um
that conflicts with our commitment to
91a
so we will not be you know
conducting business we might be talking
about scheduling you might be talking
about other kinds of things
um and we will meet again at the
chairman Pearsons
um
uh
control when he announces what our first
meeting in September would be
um but if there's nothing else I'd like
to again thank everybody and
I hope that this work session helped us
understand how complicated the issues
are how many problems
there are out there for which they're
likely not easy answers and
um that we will return
and we are during
okay
thank you